agora parece um confessionário tempo eu
aqui pra vocês eu queria gosto no
estúdio eu agora tem muito mais fácil já
consegue andar em todo o lado porque
porque depois taxa acabou não ser uns
toques vi a árvore não só a tecnologia
ainda não sei como o grupo clarín
mas vejam só é muito gostoso e está
paralisada dispositivo tecnológico é
muito obrigado
este existe óculos eu já tenho aqui tudo
montado e vou experimentar o jogo tem
tudo para salvar a funcionar é o
primeiro ante o dólar e ainda por 40
minutos e 51 sair eu vou lutar para isso
não ser tão chato estaleiro
[Música]
hoje na hora já funciona a nossa
aventura aqui
olhem sobrinhas escuro floresta pistola
o novo touch
[Música]
o são paulo ainda é isso mesmo
gosta muito medo um palhaço que um
cavalo na cabeça
agora é olhar a ó cabeça mesmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os comentários que estiverem jogos
depois de comentário nunca nunca é muito
importante é isso
o coxa